so welcome everyone
um thank you so much for coming on to
this special event my name is Franco Kim
and I teach Korean religion and culture
in the department of religious studies I
also serve um as chair of the Council on
East Asian studies
um it is my tremendous honor to host
this event for two prominent Scholars of
East Asian history politics and culture
the central theme of today's
conversation is
what is Korea
of course Korea has not existed in
isolation
and thus the more specific question is
how has Korea preserved is political and
cultural identity throughout the 5 000
years of its tumultuous history
an identity that he had shared
negotiated and contested with those of
its neighboring countries China and
Japan and Beyond
Professor Minto Yoon will give two talks
one today and the other uh this Friday
to shed some lights on this subject
and to make our conversations uh more
relevant to Modern and contemporary
international relations Professor odd
Ani westad
from the Department of History here at
Yale is kindly joining us to share
Reflections from his most and highly
acclaimed book called Empire and
righteous Nation 600 years of China and
Japan Korea relations which is also
translated into Korean
so these three talks combined luckily
for us we'll spend the entire 5 000
years of Korean history and Enlighten us
on the distinctive and common
characteristics of Korean identity in
the original and Global context
these talks will also eliminate the
precarious conditions on the Korean
peninsula in the face of a
beijing-centric order and the increasing
assertiveness of Korea with this
International influence
so today's event will be divided into
two parts Professor westad will first
speak for 30 minutes about his work
followed by Professor Yoon
Professor yoon's presentation will be
translated by my dear colleague
Professor Jun on from the University of
Michigan thank you so much he's a
professor of Korean studies
um
so he's joining um us especially for
this purpose
after the two presentations our speakers
will have the opportunity to ask
questions of each other
and we will then open the floor for your
questions uh from the audience
um
in the interest of time and due to the
video recording of today's event
um I would ask that you write your
questions on the the note cards being
distributed and I'll be reading later on
after collecting them let me briefly
introduce our two speakers
Dr Myung Chu young is a professor
amaratus of history at tongue University
and is currently professor of archeology
and summer Khan State University of
Uzbekistan
his research focuses on the history of
the Korea period from the first century
BC to the 8th Century CE as well as East
Asian Maritime history
he's published over 60 books and
numerous Journal articles he's also a
poet an Explorer and has published 14
books of poetry
Professor art Ani westad is a scholar of
modern international and global history
with a special edition in the history of
Eastern Asia from the 18th century on
he studied at the University of Oslo
before receiving his graduate degree at
the University of North Carolina in
Chapel Hill
Professor westad has published 16 books
many articles and received numerous
Awards he taught at the London School of
economic economics and Harvard history
and he joined you joined Yale three
years ago 2019 yeah and Yale snatched
him from Harvard
this event is supported by hongdam Kim's
Korean studies fund and special thanks
go to the council staff
Kathy and particularly in June Kim
without uh with logistic health I would
be deeply exhausted and sick in that
so without further Ado please join me in
welcoming Professor on usdot
[Applause]
so thank you very much wansu for that
wonderful introduction it's a it's a
great honor for me today to speak
together with Professor Yin I want to
hear what he has to say so I will be
relatively brief in presenting my book
and for those of you who are at Yale you
you know where to find me so you can you
can easily easily seek me out and
discuss these things with me so this is
a book that came out of a set of
lectures so-called right shower lectures
that I did at Harvard in 2017.
and the idea is to try to look at the
relationship between China and Korea
over a long period of time
in order to get to some of the essential
aspects
of that relationship it has been an
ever-changing relationship as you hear
me talk about in a minute
but there are also structural aspects of
it that seemed to me to connect at least
the period when I started
at the beginning of the Ming and and the
the Johnson States
uh two waters come later
so it is not without relevance
when we try to understand today's
relationship
between a new Chinese state calls itself
the People's Republic of China and and
the two under two Korean States so
history matters but not always in the
manner that we assume there is no
automaticity in this
but people learn from their history at
least they try to learn from their
history because the reason tool that
much more that you can learn from
particularly when you're dealing with
Neighbors in Korea's case very powerful
Neighbors to the to the northern and the
Western and the east as well you have to
look and and Korea has learned through
that long that long process the empires
learn as well so they learn differently
they learn in in a different form so
this is where the
title of the book comes from
Empire and and righteous Nation
and Professor Yoon has the recently
published Korean Edition to which I
wrote the new I I knew prophet
um
so by
talking about Empire that's
you it wouldn't be that difficult to
understand who I have in mind when I
speak about Empire I speak about China
in its various forms so we're dealing
with with several different incarnations
of these states uh going back to the
early early Ming era I'm going to talk a
little bit about employer in a minute in
more general terms but it's pretty clear
what the title refers to what is
it in terms of Empire now righteous and
Nation are more complicated Concepts
um and I spend uh quite a bit of time at
the beginning of this book
to talk about those those Concepts Now
by referring to Korea
again no surprise it's Korea I'm
referring to when I use the Expression
righteous Nation
as righteous I don't of course mean that
every Korean is righteous
um far from it
that is not based on historical evidence
uh I like Koreans but not that much that
I would call all of them righteous it
would also be unfair
too much to live up to
what I mean is that concepts of
righteousness
in Korean is something that has played a
particular role in Korean history going
far back uh it is an integral part of
the Neo Confucian Revolution that the
early joseon state
signaled and and symbolized and it also
became a key aspect both of trying to
understand how Korean Society should
work but perhaps more importantly over
time
at critical junctures in Korean history
as you will know better than me as a
resistance to foreign domination
so righteousness in this context of
course us many meanings but part of it
is an appeal to a Korean understanding
on the fundaments of what it means to be
Korean the essence of the discussion
that we are going to have today which of
course is varied enormously over time
but it is not in any way static but this
concept seems to me to come up again and
again in various forms
now the concept nation is of course also
if you go back to the late 14th century
problematic with regard to Korea and I'd
like us to spend some time if we have
afterwards maybe discussing them
as I was writing this book
and I I actually wrote most of the book
in Beijing when I was visiting the
uh at the King University
I started thinking very seriously about
the use of the concept nation which of
course is a 19th century European
invention right
right in order to try to understand
uh Korean history in an earlier time
period
if you use this concept with within a
framework of automaticity of course it
becomes entirely anachronistic
but if you
um as professor abush and others have
done go to the core of the European
romantic concept of nation
in terms of how it is defined then I
think it's very hard to avoid the tool
that Korea very distinct
in an Eastern Asian context
uh have some of those characteristics
already coming out of the beginning or
you being formed during the beginning
of the time period that I'm talking
about
um and particularly during the Great
East Asian war in the late in the late
16th century as has been noted by many
historians that I build on not these
Korean histories
um some of those characteristics of what
it meant to be
in a in a professed proud way a nation
in Europe in the 19th century also
seemed to be rather strikingly similar
to some not all of the concepts that
Korean identity Builds on during that
during that time
so that's why it's called Empire and
righteous Nation that's a long
explanation for a title but it is one
that really brings you I think to the
core of what I want to discuss
in this book about what states
relatively intact and what changes over
time
so the book is three parts to it
um my students when I was writing it
like to joke that the first uh the first
part
deals with about uh 500 years of
Korean relations
and the second part deals with maybe a
70 80 years of son of Korean relations
under the third part deals with the last
three weeks of certain Korean relations
it's not quite as bad as that but but
the the first part is very much about
the relationship
between two empowers based in China uh
the Ming and itching
um Andy joseon state that both of them
had to interact with going up to the
late
19th century
the second part which I call the
internationalization of East Asia
China Korea and the world goes from the
1860s 1870s up to 1992.
and then the third one deals with the
period much more recently and
particularly the future of Southern
Korean relations in the 21st century so
that is how the that is how the the book
is constructed let me talk just very
briefly about each of these three parts
before I pass the floor over to
Professor Yun and then perhaps you can
talk about some of these afterwards so I
said that
both the Ming and joseon were created
very in a very similar time period at
the end of The 14th Century very much
under the influence of the same kinds of
ideas about state
and and the construction of society the
Reconstruction of society
at the at the end of the 14th century
in both cases as
historians have shown
you could talk about a new Confucian
Revolution
it's particularly striking
in the joseon project
because of the way
the regime in sport in spite of its own
this institutes and and difficulties
with getting established as many of you
insisted
on uh the new confusion framework as
being defined
in a very direct rather concrete way
the main which by the way yes many of
you know had the same problems with
getting the Empire the dynasty
established uh also used uh forms of Neo
Confucian thinking in order to establish
that state
I don't have time to go into the
differences between the two they're very
significant differences but there were
also significant
one of the trends that I follow then
for the for the 15th and the 16th
century especially
is how various ideas and Concepts on the
Korean and on the Chinese side
mutually strengthened reinforce each
other during a a long-term conversation
among your Confucian Scholars that go on
during those two centuries or at least
up to the middle part of the
of the 16th century
uh I find that hugely
because it is one of those cases where
you find that there is a culture and
it's right to call this a culture I
think even though it's more limited than
many other forms of culture that we know
um
where you have people from very
different backgrounds speaking different
languages but of course expressing
themselves in written form in in in
similar terms exchanging ideas about how
you can build a just
and righteous State uh and also
crucially about how the relationship
between the two should what
and that is where the the issue that I
deal with more than anything else in the
first chapter really comes to
because it is one thing to Proclaim
Confucian righteousness it's another
thing to try to implement this in the
relationship between states
and that's of course something that the
southern Korean relationship has always
had had trouble with with defining
so what I find is that in spite of this
flourishing world of Exchange
of ideas and for that matter also of
goods
that existed between China and Korea
the Joseph insistence on being linked
but outside
the empire
is perhaps the core value that regulates
the relationship between the two
and and this is important because the
main in in other forms as many of you
will know and of course they change even
more than followed it were expansionist
States
it wasn't given from the beginning
particularly with this definition of a
common culture
that the joseon state would necessarily
stay outside
of these expanded expanding impulse and
particularly through through for the
chain
so in addition to the principles that
both of them base themselves on they're
also had to be a lot of practical
thinking about how this relationship
should actually work and how it should
be expressed because within the nail
confusion framework again as many of you
will know how you express things is of
incredible significance in terms of how
you should understand the reality that
you
on in terms of in terms of Concepts
so the question I ask towards the end of
that chapter
it how is how it was possible
for a much weaker State as your son
definitely was
to keep its independence and I here
deliberately use the modern term
Independence when confronted with an
Empire with Empires uh that where
expansionists and inclusionists in in
many ways
and my answer to that question is
manifold
one which I think is truly important is
through
the principle of always knowing more
about the Empire than the Empire knows
about you
that could be a fancy name for
intelligence and it is to some extent
though it was much voided and
intelligence so the tribute missions
um
that took place to to China to the Ming
and then to the Qing afterwards well
also fantastic opportunities for
gathering information about the Empire
and the Empire's intentions
and I would go as far as saying that if
it weren't for them then joseon would
have been much more exposed with regard
to China uh than what was the case uh in
reality particularly during uh the
transition from from Ming to Ching which
I don't have time to go into that today
but it was of course highly problematic
from uh from a Korean point of view so
knowing more about the Empire than the
Empire knows about you is a very
important portable ones
the the other part
is of course to show
us
joseon State showed
increasingly as you get into the into
the 17th and the 18th century
that you can be better practitioners
of Confucianism of neo confucianism then
what even the Empire can
this is a remarkable time period when
you think about it in ideological terms
in the relationship between the Qing and
Andy Joseph
um how is it possible for the joseon
Kings to get away after the
the big changeover and after having
confronted and lost against the Qing
armies in in in the early 17th century
not just to to keep its own independence
but keep on venerating Long dead Ming
emperors
who of course the swollen enemies of the
Qing Dynasty that was no in case in
China and get away with it
and the insistence that what confusion
Scholars and the confusion quote
juson did in this context was to
practice righteousness with regard to
the
uh the Emperors that had gone before and
that had had a relationship to to Korea
I call it in the book A vassal
relationship it's it's hard to find an
English term that actually works
because the important thing for me is
that Korea is linked to the Empire but
outside
so whatever way you want to express
they were allowed to go on doing that
because of that shared uh inheritance
that even the Ching even the Ching
respected
and that level
of even rather contrary signocentrism
is of course then what gets into trouble
increasingly towards the end of the 19th
century when when the chain itself is
receding it's not that the joseon elite
are particularly fond of the Qing they
are not but living in a world where the
Chinese Empire a Chinese Empire that
Korea has so long been linked to in one
form or another
or for both enormous challenges
maybe first and foremost in the
relationship to Japan
but also enormous opportunities for
rethinking what kind of state what kind
of of State formation
uh that are truly independent uh Korea
should have
now
that's what then defines the second
chapter of
of the book
because it is in many ways an enforced
internationalization of East Asia that
takes place during this during this
period and first first and foremost
because of Japanese aggression
um against against Korean for that
matter against against China as well but
also because
finding framework
so far removed
from what you find in the early 19th
century never never mind the the 1720
and the 18th century
my
verdict in the book is that in spite of
being occupied
of being colonized using its
independence to Japan
Korea and being
you know suffering the consequences of
them
in Korea
you have this transition over to new
forms of thinking about nation and
nationalism
coming out of the late 19th century
well could almost go as as far as saying
that part of the tragedy of Korea in the
20th century
was that just as these new concepts of
of what Korea consisted of com came of
age the country was occupied by Japan so
so these forms of of nationalism all had
to grow up in Exile and we know what
happens to nationalisms that grow up in
in excellence they get hypercharged
and they get absolutely convinced that
the only version of a future for a
country is the version that their
particular brand of of concept of
nationalism consistent
so by saying that I'm not saying the
same thing as some historians have been
saying
including some American histories that
the division the origins of the division
of Korea should be sought in those early
divergences
of Korean nationalism I don't think that
is enough of itself as opposed to the
effect I mean the division of Korea came
out of the second world war and the Cold
War and the division of the two
occupation zones without any doubt but
what it did was that it fueled the the
concepts of of nation and National aims
that then took both in the South and in
the north it shaped and formed them in
ways that are really really significant
so that is the
top 10 to the final part of the book
when I talk about relations between
China and the two Korean States today
I'm not going to go into that too deep
here you can you can read a book now
also in Korean for those
but I'm basically saying that much of
the current Chinese policy towards the
two Korean States
is based on some of those principles and
ideas that come out of the post but in a
new kind of format
and that new kind of format is
definitely based on
China's own rights the plc's own rights
as an economic power over the post
generation
some ideas in that rights have come from
Korea just as some ideas about the
organization of confusion Society in the
Ming in the 16th century came from Korea
but there are also an increasing and to
me worrisome level within the PLC of
developing a a form of Chinese
nationalism that projects to Korea to
both careers and to other countries in
the region
a new form of sonocentrism that go
beyond what you saw even during the Ming
and probably also the the Qing Empire
um
it is a form of of putting China at the
center
that asks not for linkages and that form
of intellectual cultural inclusion
uh even under pressure has happened in
the case of the chain uh both in
diplomatic and strategic terms
uh and will punish countries at a
borders that do not uh
profess to the same understanding of
that centrality that Central role of
China
uh as the current uh PLC leaders
um professor that worries me it doesn't
not because of the way some of our
American colleagues are saying oh this
is bringing China back to the way it was
during the Great dynasties it's not
doing that
it is it is presenting us with it's a
new kind of problem in terms of how
China's fantastic rights admirable
rights
will influence the smaller countries
that surround it whether that will be a
Cooperative home
or or an authoritarian and and and
forced form of cooperation between China
and these countries so there that's
where I where I leave it in terms of the
book it's a very brief book
uh so you might be able to read it in a
couple of afternoons if you have an
interest in it I don't write many brief
books so so if you want to read a brief
book of mine this this might be a good a
good place and stuff so that is what I
had to say thank you
[Applause]
thank you
however my name is okay
I'm a professor and poet and sometimes I
say to I'm a Explorer
sometimes sometimes okay
and
my main study is a Korean ancient Korean
history and especially specialized
cochlear corporate kingdom is very
important in Korean histories and
everything and especially Maritime
history is Asian this is my main student
main study
I'm sure
oh
um the books are written me
today is very important to me the Korean
just Americans and the world well this
is a reason it is my idea
um yes
but now a lot of people are interested
in East Asia especially Korea's place
within East Asia
but a lot of people have misperceptions
and misconceptions about East Asia and
Korea
uh first this there's this idea that
Korea is an appendage or a connection or
connected uh branch of Chinese history
and thought
there's also this idea that Korea's
history and culture is limited to what
happened in the Korean Peninsula yes
okay yes the homie Kingdom and the
Landover morning
those expressions hermit Kingdom and the
land of the morning calm are expressions
that appeared in the late 19th century
and were often used by foreigners to
refer to Korea
and that stuck and that's how people
continue to refer to Korea
and there is the misperception that
Korea has continued to be a nation that
was oppressed by either China or Japan
yeah
and these two kingdoms in the in uh in
the past
are often understood just simply as
parts of Chinese history
and these claims have been Advanced by
scholars in China recently
and there is the claim that has been
Advanced that ancient China ancient
Korea was dominated by Japan
um
I'm a historian I work with facts and I
believe that these claims are not based
on facts
we need to look at Korean history so
let's start with this map this is a map
of Eurasia
foreign
there are six major Paths of connections
that connected Eurasia
produce
the most important are the three that he
just pointed out the step Road the Silk
Road and the maritime trade route Road
uh on the bottom though
and it's very important to understand
these Geographic developments to
understand Korea properly
Koreans use the word the Han people Palm
peoples with the nation and Egos
and this is very different from the way
the word nation is used by other
countries
I'll explain what that means next time
Friday okay Friday yes Friday
so the emergency as it says there the
emergence of the nation's ancestor or
the origins of the Korean uh ethnic
group dates back to uh BC 15 to 12
Century BCE
there wasn't a complete radical
displacement of the people in the Korean
peninsula
so a lot of cultures and people came in
but it blended with the existing local
cultures and traditions because the
local cultures and traditions were so
strong
there were two occasions when Korea was
conquered these three are the colors
okay
um
but that didn't result in the complete
transformation of the Korean people
because
and this is a unique characteristic that
makes it very different from the Mongols
Turks and others okay
so he uh Professor Yoon calls Korea a
living and a cultural and also a
historical community
and because these are so strong Koreans
have this a strong sense of community
a lot of people are interested in the
issue of how Koreans emerge or where
Koreans
Professor yoon's theory is that eight
route for use for people to migrate into
the Korean
peninsulaikum
and the steplodu and Lodo is
so the three routes that were mentioned
earlier through the vital area and also
through the Silk Road and the maritime
route were the three most important
roster which people entered the
peninsula
early Koreans were influenced very
heavily by Northern peoples especially
those who speak the Altec language
but there was also a culture that was
transmitted via India and Southeast Asia
into Korea because
so in Professor yoon's view the best way
to understand the emergence of Korea is
to understand as the foundation the uh
the entrance of people through the
northern route but also supplemented and
grown through the entry of people
through the maritime Southern Realm
the theory that uh the native people of
Korea originated from the Korean
Peninsula this is a theory that uh is
popular in North Korea
I'll provide an alternative Theory
I divide East Asian civilizations into
these three separate civilizations
Chinese civilization one and the second
golden civilization and the Eastern
civilization
he divided into these three
civilizations Chinese Northern and
Easter
is
so in the Eastern civilization he
includes
um uh the Japanese archipelago Korean of
course the Lion's Adventure as well
foreign
this way
uh Professor Yoon to understand East
Asia created a new model and called it
the East Asian Mediterranean Sea yeah
[Music]
and uh since 20 years ago since he
developed it this theory has been in
wide use in other parts of the world
it the the Mediterranean Sea as you can
see here connects various points on this
map and uh and connects various regions
and countries today uh into one region
interchange
Chronicles
so his theory is different from previous
theories and that he he plays his career
at the core of the geopolitics of the
East Asian Mediterranean Sea he puts
Korea as the Hub of the geoeconomics of
that of the Mediterranean Sea he also
puts Korea in The Interchange point of
the geoculture of the Mediterranean East
Asian Mediterranean Sea and last but not
least an expression that he coined
himself he puts Korea at the heart of
the geomentology of the East Asian
Mediterranean Sea animal
but this doesn't does not apply to the
chosen period
this is a map that was created in the
chosen Theory
is
so this what you see here is a
conception of Korea that is no more than
a thousand years old and prior to that
the Korean conception of territory was
much larger and it encompassed
everything from areas up in Manchuria
down to the Japanese Islands
he's just going to skip the
periodications because it's well known
is the uh is the country or Kingdom that
Koreans consider to be the very first
Kingdom Korean Kingdom to have ever
existed uh but Professor Yoon actually
prefers to call it not old Jose which is
the literal translation of the word but
rather proto-chosan
this is my book on okay
territory roughly coincides with what is
today laodon Peninsula Nigeria and also
Middleton North regions of the Korean
Peninsula
swords
I use these four things as evidence to
claim that that was the territories of
proto-josa
there are a lot of domains these are
huge stone structures that were
constructed everywhere apparently
there's over 40 000 of these I didn't
know that uh currently in existence
that currently exists in southern
Peninsula
that's him
so you can see how big it is okay
this is North Korea today
there are a lot of these
because
this is in North Charlotte province in
in South Korea today
and just that region alone there are
over 20 000
in the north and south of the Korean
Peninsula are different
it's not a fundamental difference but
rather a difference in style
this is a typical sword from the
proto-choson period
pretty isn't it yes
one two three
so he finds a logic in this and he
believes that it can be divided into
three parts
he believes that this wasn't actually
meant to be used as a weapon but rather
as a ritual to implement
of the same area
and this is an example of that blade
that was found in Japan
so that's a drawing of of the thing that
you see on the right there I was done by
his wife
the husband and wife work together to
reconstruct Korea's past
you
nationalists Patriots
so these are bronze mirrors and he
believes that the bronze mirrors in
China and the ones that you found are in
the northern steps and also the bronze
mirrors found in the Korean Peninsula
are all different in style um
so some bronze mirrors around the third
Century of the Common Era can be from
China can be found in Japan but there
are a lot more that actually came from
the Korean peninsula
can you see the words
000 lines and then it's uh some
um
this is distance between the lines is
what you see up there
technology
and he believes that this is evidence of
incredible technology
the ability or the capacity to create
bronze mirrors and bronze swords was
means that they were at the top of the
technological game
he wants to once again re-emphasize the
fact that bronze mirrors are produced in
China and the bronze mirrors produced in
Korea are very different yeah
now that you've heard what I had to say
you can see the significance of what you
see here on this map right
so when we go beyond the narrow
understanding of nation and we
understand it culturally you can see
that Korea encompasses a territory that
is much bigger than the way it's
imagined today
so in the interest of time he's going to
skip over the fact that there are
dolmens that are found in other areas
that are currently uh uh China today
so around the turn of the uh the
Millennium in Korea what you see is the
rise of uh Three Kingdoms
the first is you see here
foreign
River and also middle Manchuria
so we should take note of the fact that
the origins of proto-chosan and also
Coda lie outside of the Korean Peninsula
yeah
and he considered himself or called
himself the son of heaven
and he believes that the heaven here
does not refer to the heaven used in the
uh old Joe Tex or the Confucian Classics
but rather to the heaven that is
worshiped up by the northern step people
like the Mongols
and so he believes that the Google
inherited much from Proto Chosen and
also from the northern step people yeah
so this is a painting of the father of
the founder of uh
koguria and he's considered to be a God
in heaven this and this is a painting
that's currently housed in North Korea
today
um near what uh they believe to be or in
the shrine where they believe uh to be
his tomb
um
he used the name of that God for the
Wrath that he took himself to go from an
island in Korea all the way over to
Japan just to show you that the 7 000
years of Maritime trade and exchange did
indeed happen and could happen
foreign
in China over to Korea
so the travel from China to an island
called was 17 days and he also took a
raft to travel all the way over to Japan
as well which took I think he said 43
days out of which 10 were actually uh he
spent in in Seoul
I look weak but uh
um
so uh he wants to make sure that uh he
makes it very clear that what you're
actually seeing here is not necessarily
a concept of territory but rather area
of influence and this area of influence
was real and it reached as you can see
far really up north into territories
that are still uh subjects of
controversy today especially among
Scholars of China
and he reconstructs this area of
influence using archaeological and
textual evidence so he doesn't think
that there's really any room for
um different interpretations
similar so at the height of Google's
history China was in disarray
fighting amongst each other and uh
kingdoms like cogurio and other Northern
tribes took advantage of this fact uh to
increase their influence in that area
I'll tell you a fun story
so that fun story is the folk the folks
that you see here the roron I think they
travel far out west and they've reached
all the way over to Italy uh where they
settled
was able to take advantage of the split
of China into the northern where in the
northern way in the southern song and
engaged in Long Distance trade
and the person who uh who facilitated
all this is uh known to be uh
you see here
the Steely is 6.39 meters tall and it
contains over over 1700 words
what he wants to emphasize is not
necessarily the size or the Ambitions of
the king but rather the place of Korea
within the larger geopolitical
systems
and what he wants to emphasized is that
the place of in this larger geopolitical
system was a peaceful one and that's
what they aspired and that was the world
view at the time
and the beauty
and the logic and meaning
so he wrote something about this Theory
and the title contains those words that
you just heard Beauty logic
and so on
um
that's the king's tomb yeah
and it's a pyramid
and this is what that pyramid looks like
together
tombs like this there are over 12
Manchuria but the only one that
currently remains is this one that you
see here
on Friday he'll talk he'll delve deeper
into the philosophical uh meanings of
that too
so please come Friday
so in year 427 moved its capital to what
is today North Korea uh to its new
Palace the anaka palace
and the castle and that's a castle from
that herd
and this is a depiction of a warrior of
an army that boasted one of the most
powerful armies at the time
so this predicts the Turkish depictions
of the Warriors by about a hundred years
and on Friday I'll talk about the
function of these words
[Music]
and at the beginning for that reason
they uh frequently had skirmishes with
Google but they later started to have
wars with their neighbor in the South
um
and around 4th Century CE they began to
expand their areas of influence to the
Japanese archipelago
this is First Capital and the river that
you see there is the famous Han river
which splits the capital yugosity of
soul
you can see the outlines of the original
wall of the capital and you can see that
it's located right by the river which
means that the this was a maritime
Kingdom
a lot of these ancient cities from this
period are Maritime cities and they were
designed to take advantage of Maritime
that's his sister
so this is uh a castle that was used by
koguda as their military fort
Europe actually
and that's why you see around the Han
River
pyramids that look a lot like the
pyramids from Europe
so there are a lot of these pyramids
from the Google period in Manchester
United
he went there 70 times
the last Kingdom to emerge the founder
is known to be a man named
Khan
okay
um uh
um in this context refers to the ruler
or the nation Genghis Khan no
foreign
[Music]
is a little off it should be a bit lower
at the top there but what you're seeing
here is Shila at the height of its power
is
so Koreans tend to uh prefer to see
coguru as being much larger than it
actually was but the territories that
would uh dispatch officials and
controlled um indirectly was a much
smaller area
he wants he highlighted this fact in red
here because he wants to emphasize the
fact that around the 5th of the 6th
Century uh there seem to be culturally a
connection between Shilla and the
shungnu up North
this is a very complicated question
is
so these are tombs from when you uh
excavate them what you find are remnants
of cultural patterns that you can
connect with the northern people like
the orange the Paris
is hands down the single uh the most
prolific producer of these of golden
crowns
the fact yes
so that crown that you see there on the
right is from Kazakhstan and there are a
lot of people who draw
connections
and on Friday he's going to show you all
the crowns
foreign
so there's another kingdom or Federation
known as Kaya and he believes that these
are Maritime city-states or police these
are really smallish city-states that
came together as a federation and that's
his theory oh sorry
and those are the the different colors
represent the different city-states
known as the city state and the children
so
um
cultural group they actually began at
the southern tip of the Korean Peninsula
but they began to expand their
territories on areas of influence into
the Japanese islands and uh more Kaya
influence began to grow as a consequence
uh deeper in the middle of the peninsula
pieces
so archaeological evidence points to uh
movement of Kaya folk into the Japanese
islands around the 4th Century BCE but
textual material from Japan points to
that happening sometime around the turn
of the Millennium
the closest place to get to Japan from
Korea is the city of Busan which is
and it's an area where you find a lot of
Kaya period
and that's a cultural artifact that was
Unearthed near Busan and you can see
that it's the remains of the of the
accoutrement
and obviously it was influenced heavily
by poguda culture okay
a lot of people don't understand Korean
history but what they really don't
understand is that Korea was heavily
engaged in Maritime trade and
interaction with other areas
this is a book about uh Maritime history
in Korea
it's been translated to Vietnamese
they tried to translate into Chinese but
they didn't get the permissions to do so
it was published in Chinese but in
Korean
he really wants this book to be
translated into Japanese and English as
well yes
this is a depiction of the maritime
trade routes of Google
and these are the maritime trade routes
is
so the northern way was established by
the chambe people from up North and
those who fled the incursion of the
northern way they established the
countries down in the kingdoms out in
the South the song The Southern Chi the
Liang and the and the Jinn
and the Schiller folk also traveled
across the street they see to the
Japanese Islands through these Maritime
trade routes
we use archaeological artifacts and also
Japanese records like the kojiki and the
Nihon Shoki to reconstruct these
traditions
and that's the path of influence of Kaya
and I explained all of this in my book
on Ancient Japan
this is a very important bed this is an
international war that takes place
during this period at the end of the 6th
Century
so the system of the three countries
China Korea and Japan emerges in the
wake of this International war and this
was really the consequence of tongue
emerging victorious in this world
and it's a war that lasted over 70 years
economic power and the
to collapse the culture clubs and those
are the reasons behind the war
neurology
so it's a war between
China and Cobra but in direct or
indirect ways everybody else uh the
surrounding states and policies were
involved in this International War as
well
and this is what that war basically
and that's how many soldiers were
involved in the war between sway that is
the predecessor to the Tang Dynasty and
Google
Dynasty loses that war with Kubota and
collapses in 40 years old
with 500 ships and so on but they uh
actually lose that battle
and these are again all based on
children
and the third is the uh Alliance that
was forged with between Tang China and
Shula which eventually results in the
collapse of kukuru
um
is going to collapse as well those red
dots that you saw in the Japanese
Islands those were forts established by
the immigrants and you can see from this
how the intimate relationship between
the pector immigrants
and the significance of this event is
that it's roughly around this time that
we begin to see the rise of what we call
today Japan today
and the name
it emerges during this period and you
can see the significance of this
I'll end in five minutes
and this is advanced in old Chinese
histories dynastic histories
history it states clearly that the King
was attempting to recover koguda's old
territory hence the Appalachian
successor States
and in wooden tablets and also ceramic
dishes are found in Japan they refer to
the envoys from here as actually envoys
or diplomats sent to or from so you can
see that poguda had a very a close
relationship
and from the fact that used its own
error names shows you how independent
they were
chosen for example cannot use its own
because it was under the influence of
Chinese cultures
were different in this regard yeah
and there are a lot of records of them
identify identifying themselves as The
Descendants from the god of Heaven
is
so the this reconstructions of the
territories of party are based on
archaeological evidence uh and the the
Far Eastern Northeastern territories the
archaeological evidence was done of
course
this is not my field of expertise so
I've relied on the expertise of others
this is a depiction done by the Chinese
of the uh the fort the Palace of pate
and that's the front gate of that and
this is my last slide um
the Vikings of Asia
is
in the 220 years they sent more than 34
envoys
and 1100 immigrants had crossed the
street but then they were a force of
return
I've traveled
people had to across the ocean they had
to rely on the northeasterly winds
and that's why I call them the Vikings
of Asia
there may be Scholars of Japan and
Japanese students here yes
Japanese are very proud of their
Maritime history a lot of this was
reconstructed using Japanese sources on
this subject
finally the time has arrived that you
are waiting for this is the end of the
lecture thank you all very much
[Applause]
right so why don't we give an
opportunity to our speakers to ask
questions of each other
so uh Professor do you have any question
for for
absolutely
the exposition fascinating it in terms
of looking at the various stages of the
development of of Korean history and I
know that your own expertise is is
connected earlier
foreign
s of this larger Korean area that
[Music]
so is there any recent genetic research
that will show some of the connections
between the original inhabitants in
these areas and neighboring groups
because it's always a big question in
terms of how these people have traveled
in terms of settlement right but also
sometimes with a little bit of luck
genetic research eni research can tell
us something about how cultures trap
between them
[Music]
so
um scholars believe that
the inhabitants of the Korean peninsula
in terms of their genetic makeup and
whatnot had already been established
pretty much by the somewhere between the
fifth of the 7th Century City
So based on textual records we know that
there was connections between the
tungustic and the uh people up
in the northern steps with people who
will come to inhabit the Korean
peninsula tonight
so he did this is tough so
so he distinguishes between a core group
and then a periphery group and the
periphery group will actually establish
Conquest dynasties in what are
territories in China today
so there is some DNA evidence to suggest
that the the vast majority came from the
north there is some DNA evidence to
suggest that there was an immigration
from the south as well but Professor
Yoon himself does not really think that
to understand the formation of the
historical cultural Community during
this period that DNA DNA is very
important
and it really depends time where you
collect the DNA evidence so that's why
he doesn't give it too much credits
so the big difference between uh the
Chinese today and Koreans is that the
Koreans are connected or descendants of
the northern mongoloids
so there's the northern mongoloids in
the southern mongoloids
so Koreans are mainly descendants of the
northern mongoloines who belong to the
Altair linguistic group
there are more recent research has come
to criticize or deny the uh the I'll
talk language group Theory but there's
plenty of evidence to suggest otherwise
and he believes that in our culture uh
in our blood and so on there is language
culture right and and language there are
still strong traces of the northern step
culture and history
I I had just one more question if I may
uh I was fascinated by this concept of
the Eastern or the Eastern Asian
Mediterranean okay so this this idea
about how influence spread and how how
goods were exchanged uh in terms of this
um
like you fascinated by
not surprising since I come from Nova
[Music]
so so I was wondering in terms of the
kind of of narrative vessels the ships
that would that we think were being used
for these kinds of exchanges were these
different kinds of ships do we know
anything about that at all and was
shipbuilding technology because there
must have been a lot of ships going in
different directions was that influenced
across the various areas or are there
very different kinds of ships that
contributed to this is
foreign
[Music]
technology China was at the top uh but
unfortunately we don't have records from
Korea or Japan tell me more about it
period in Japan where you look at the
murals and you can see images of ships
and we can use those to sort of uh guess
what the ships actually look like
so he uh Professor Yoon says that the
ships used in the eastern and the
Western Seas were very different and the
ones used in the Eastern Sea the one
that connected what is Russia Today
Korea and Japan were probably much
closer in design to the Viking ships
and the sails themselves have to be
square yeah
and he believes that this design had to
be used because of the size of the waves
and the need to rely on the northeast
so Chinese sources they tell you exactly
how the ships
on far more details about that from um
and so he doesn't deny the signifi the
sophistication of Chinese shipbuilding
technology
okay since we don't have much time why
don't we just jump into uh
just sharing with you maybe two or three
questions from doria's the most kind of
obvious and funny one okay why did you
feel so ambitious to cross the waters
between Korea and Japan to understand
the experience yourself
he believes that history is based on
action
is
you can't understand their happiness
their sorrow their pain or anything
unless you experience it for yourself
you have to experience it for yourself
to just even get a glimpse of what the
experiences back in the day were like
and he believed that there's a meaning
of existence not only to human beings to
every single thing
and he believed that that was the way of
thought and the world view of the
ancient Korean people well basically
okay okay this question
um
I thought my handwriting was really bad
but wow it's kind of archaeological
projects you
you mentioned several cultural
connections between ancient Korean
people and altered peoples
as far as I know
the hypothesis positive relationship
between Japanese Korean and various age
inner Asian
uh languages has been finally I gotten
languages
uh has been largely disproven by
American and European linguists
[Music]
okay I know so what does the category
outtake mean to you and those Korean
language
um
um on culture fall under the category or
is it separate but related to it is
foreign
he is he understands that linguists uh
now deny the altered uh cultural sphere
and linguistic Spirit Theory but as a
historian he believes that such a sphere
did exist and that it is very useful in
understanding the um the cultural
interactions between the northern steps
and the Korean Peninsula sorry
cultural sphere in the outside mountain
range but he believes that it should be
a place further west above Uzbekistan
and the grasslands there and that is
Ukraine very important I'm sorry so we
have two a question the following
question you can just answer yes or no
okay okay I'm sorry was the founder of
kojo son um
proto-choson yes ever honored in the
same way that Kita or tangun were
Korean people
no no
okay
um
so then answer the question directly but
um he says that the word chosen appears
and very early Chinese sources it also
appears in the 13th century Korean
Source this is a very important Source
known as the sample Musa and there's
clear evidence of the fact that
successor States
um clearly look to the tools on as the
state that they were succeeding and so
he believes that there is that
connection there um
so Scholars distinguish between
but this is not the this is something
that Scholars do but not something that
really exists
it's a very difficult question
so he finds it very difficult himself to
actually answer the question of kija and
women
but I do actually Advance my own
personal views as history
so as a scholar he denies the
um the theory of kijaduzan but he does
accept vimanjoson as part of Korean
history
okay the time is up I'm the person of
keeping the promise so so
um those of you who uh wrote questions
and haven't heard the answer you can
actually come forward and ask him in
person but thank you again Professor
Westside for coming and it's a wonderful
talk and thank you Professor Yoon um
this this Friday at 12 we're gonna have
the second part of the talk with Korean
food okay so please come thank you so
much you guys thank you have a wonderful
evening
foreign